paris désert respire mieux
du 13 mars au 13 avril le satellite
copernicus sentinelle 5 p a observé la
france mais aussi l'espagne et le nord
de l'italie pour l'agencé spatiale
européenne comparé aux données du mois
de mars de l'année dernière et grâce aux
travaux de l'institut météorologique
royale des pays bas
ces images révèlent une impressionnante
baisse de la pollution atmosphérique
-48% de dioxyde d'azoté à madrid avec
15% de marge d'erreur la baisse est à
peu près équivalente à milan et à rome
quant à paris la diminution atteint même
50 4% à l'origine de cette amélioration
la réduction du trafic routier bien sûr
mais pas seulement
avec la baisse des activités économiques
et industriels le satellite observe une
baisse de la combustion d'énergies
fossiles
mercredi 1er avril le secrétaire général
de l'onu a estimé que la terre vivaient
je cite sa pire crise mondiale depuis
que l'onu a été fondée il ya 75 ans l'
agence spatiale européenne veut aussi
sensibiliser la population pour tirer
les leçons de cette expérience
selon le dernier rapport de l'agencé
européenne de l'environnement sur la
qualité de l'air de 2019
le dioxyde d'azoté est responsable de
68000 décès prématurés par rendant lieu
dont 7500 en france